I don't like these people but the
problem the bigger problem is the
ideology it has to be defeated which is
Sharia law it's not the religion of
Islam I care about I you know the part
of Islam that's religion
I have respectful which is prayers you
know all the assumptions of the religion
but what I criticize is political Islam
just date and the Sharia law and the
jihad concept and the medical
institution that you have your neighbors
take not the Jews and Christians as your
friends so how can you live in
compatibility with the judeo-christian
people as a Muslim you can't you can't
you have under Islam you the
commandments is to really don't be kind
to them don't respect them or live in
peace with them except if you're a
minority and that's that I'm reading
from the so you're right is that game
perfect I I have a lot of respect really
for many many Muslims because many of
them don't even know don't even know
what then what's in their books they
don't know what's in their books I go
with a little there may be that but I
feel that you're somewhat so in your
opinion how do you combat this extremism
that has taken over the middle
in some small pockets I wouldn't say
that's a millions of people that reside
in the area or the billion people that
are Muslims in the world also believe in
killing Jews and Muslims and many of the
other really really terrible things that
you've said and some of them are
happening in a minority but I wouldn't
say that over a billion people believe
in this extremist pilot idea
so how do you kind of he doesn't want
fighter she's she's she's a lovely young
lady are you Muslim students who are
writing in Cairo who are crying and bled
and died in their Tahrir Square unlike
you they want to live with freedom they
were delivered democracy the only
difference between you and me is I
believe that Sharia law is behind all of
the problems the problem to end the
violence in the Muslim world we have to
start with ending the teaching of eggs
in the schools see did you did you were
you brought up here the way we are
brought up in the spoons
it makes us three such victims victims
of the West
victims of the Jews in such a way that
the nicest person you will need if you
give me a garden you tell me is a job
well shoot them it's not that they are
evil it's the education they are the
education yes I want yes yes in the
Middle East
I'll tell you what the only schools that
not teaching hate hatred well when I was
in Egypt I went to British schools but
it was the remnants of the British
before they left Egypt and in that day
we never thought about hating Jews but
you don't even have to learn it some
from the from the school it's everywhere
open the TV Arab TV you see the girls
and and check that and in the children
children children
shows for children they're putting all
the new girls and the teachers saying
okay and now tell me sweetheart who does
God hate the most
and the little three-year-old she hardly
even understands what she's saying
this girl is not evil she just said
she's just puppet it's their children
and why because God told us in the Quran
to hate them why are we supposed to hit
them sweetheart because they're AIDS and
pigs and enemies of all Allah this is on
Egyptian TV she was an Egyptian brush
wasn't even Palestinian she was an
Egyptian girl
I'm Saudi TV solji it is it is an
epidemic I grew up in these groups it's
an epidemic
if you stop that kind of education you
will start bring the humanity of its
children out because if you put I
guarantee you if you put children
together to be brought up Jews blacks
whites Asians Hispanics everything they
will never discriminate or hate each
other it's only the input from the
adults that makes children hate or even
know this place they don't notice -
children don't notice race
they don't notice if you're a Chinese or
white or
they my daughter well you know it if she
was in Egypt she would hate her but they
were brought up here they they went to
school here and my daughter would tell
me mom I wanted to be like my friend
she's so she's the best girl she's my
mother and this girl was the cutest
little black girl I've ever seen
to her she was her mother because she
never got an input and input from that
as adults who put things in the minds of
children and her children are not any
different and if children are not born
to him I was an anti-semite
I would I I grew up until maybe thirty
five hating Jews when I came to America
my boss I didn't know he was Jewish and
minute I knew it's just a food now he's
gonna eat me now he's gonna you know
because I was brought up under the
intense indoctrination they had Apollo
upon in Egypt just to prove to you how
the education and the media can make
people ninety six percent of Egyptian
said that the main problem in love is
Israel the Jews tell me with all the
problems of Egypt the economic they are
education they let you see the the
pollution need I mean look at the
pollution oh my god with all this
economic political problems of Egypt the
Egyptian people when they were
questioned there 96% said didn't say our
economy our dictatorships our oppression
how forty five percent of Egyptians are
illiterate in their own language in
Arabic they have never even read the
Koran they are literally didn't say
illiteracy he said it
what does that mean is the result of
what what does it you have you have to
do in the internal affairs of agent
nothing nothing
we're just calling Cairo like you you
want this good collisionless of French
school but they teach the same thing you
were saying it's amazing even in the
French cap is cool but the Jesuits when
the architectural comes in the classroom
yeah and then we're talking about the
crime and they'll talk about the how can
I go to heaven yeah if I was a sinner if
I was a sinner all my life how can go to
heaven well you have to do it is kill an
infidel yeah kill them and this is an
eighth grade yeah
how can i it's amazing i want i want
people who oppose my religion I let you
I I wanna just tell you these are from
Egypt they went to schools who were
westernized school we were in
westernized schools where we were not in
the public schools of the government
that were more intense my religious
teacher in st. Clare's college of time
used to tell us how I mean Julia was
represented Mohamed in a very bad way
she said Mohamed killed the Jews and
because they deserve to be killed he
killed eight hundreds of them and and
and in India in one try and he she was
saying it not as something to be ashamed
of she was saying it as something to be
profitable to be proud of
he killed the infidels and God gave him
all the power
to conquer all in she was saying what
what we would look at as as as
assassination mass assassination as
something to be proud
however I feel very strongly that you
might be a little bit confused
especially about the country that you
are currently in yes legal lynch mobs
legal death penalty legal sterilization
legal imprisonment without charge legal
torture legal proxy wars legal cept of
resources in other countries legal
invasions and occupations the CIA
influencing elections and other
countries
let the fight outside where these
maggots I lived under the two systems I
would never exchange America for
anything from leaving Sharia I was held
against me Egyptians under Gamal Abdel
Nasser
we're not allowed to leave the country
for many many years the minute the doors
are opened under Sadat
I left I do not I really think it's very
toxic to live in a country that you
don't agree with and you think is bad
in Egypt because of Sharia and thank God
I kissed the ground of America every day
as a woman in America my dignity as a
woman in all rights under the law of
course there are oppression this there
is no perfect society see the problem is
some Americans think the ideal society
the perfect society can't happen I have
news for you just like every human being
is not perfect every society is not
perfect there are women who are depleted
in America in their homes right but if
you call the police then will snatch
that man cooking who to beat you and he
would be in jail in the Muslim world
under Sharia he has the right to beat
you know policemen way we will get him
hit her home her old father cannot
protect her so thank God I have the
police in America in America I can go to
the police and I don't need witnesses
smaller than your thumb that was
American law
it's not an arrival it's not the law of
Egypt it's nothing - it's not the law of
America it's not the Bible
so no need to mention it ma'am first of
all miss darbus thank you so much for
your courage and you said early in your
talk that there's a gap in Egypt between
democracy and Sharia we have been told
since this revolt uprising however you
would probably better have a better word
for it we've been told in America that
this is a democracy movement freedom
movement and yet you say the
overwhelming majority of Egyptians
embrace Sharia how do we expose the
truth of what's really happening over
there
you've got everybody from the deputy
national security advisor I think mr.
clapper saying the Muslim Brotherhood is
not a religious we're going to save that
I mean you've got all these lies that
are that are being promulgated how do we
cut through that next buzz what's really
happening Americans know what's going on
there are certain people in America
certain politicians and certain people
in Indonesia who purposefully don't want
to expose the truth American people
because not not all American people are
are exposed to my speeches or all the
truth and some people just watch the
evening news and that's how they learn
so the problem the West doesn't want to
expose the truth because the truth is
too big for the West
it's too big it's too big for the
Westerner
the only thing I find that the West is
is moths is when when somebody makes a
statement in the Middle East that the
Jews were responsible for the bombing in
Sinai and that was not really people
that did it is the Jews did it to
embarrass the Egyptian government why
don't you call that politicians and have
a debate with him on American why why
why do you let this propaganda so I find
that that that they have decided
somebody on top in America have decided
that the policy of covering up for the
atrocities that are going on in Muslim
world today against Christians against
Jews against Muslims too because you
know radicals and Islamists are killing
Muslims who dare to speak up so they
decide that that let them evolve on
their own that's not possible
I have a feeling this is what's going on
but at least don't come to us and call
us Islamophobes
that's I mean they sometimes go too far
but by and that's the truth in Egypt
today seventy five percent want to live
under Sharia law the movement was done
majority with my students but the
students now are being swallowed by the
the brother yes sir my name's Dave
Bailey by the way I was down there when
you I launched former Muslims United in
DC it was one who see there I'm glad to
see you here a quick personal story that
leads to the question I had a college
student who was a Muslim who worked for
me and we're very good friends
everything's you know very close and she
confided a lot in me and she was really
concerned about you know all the
problems going on Middle East
she was seeking to find a way to bring
about peace so she goes with her family
said this is a very close personal
relationship so she goes off with her
family to Lebanon for three weeks okay
comes back and she happens to walk in
while I'm on lunch and I'm touching a
little bit of the news and it just so
happened that the Twin Towers is being
shown okay on the TV when she walked in
and and they're talking about you know
who really did it and she goes you guys
are still talking about this here I mean
back in Lebanon everybody knows that it
was Mossad who did it and you know and
he's all video is conspiracy the Jews
and the Americans are covering it up
and one day oh my gosh and the thing is
is she was going to this is gonna be a
joint project she was gonna go you know
when she went there she was gonna do
research how to make bring about peace
and you know everything she was gonna do
this and share this with me because I
was curious about that perspective over
there but she would never when she came
back right okay and long story short she
ended up going to the University of
Delaware Matata Khan got ahold of her if
anybody knows who he is
and basically she turned against me okay
now did the question we talked about
there's plenty of very nice Muslim
people you know it's not religion that
people can be graded and I've used that
a hundred percent but the question is
how can you tell which ones are nice
Muslims I'm trusting count on and which
ones are the ones who are
misrepresenting themselves lying okay
look at bad energy blue so we should I'm
not here to blame Muslim people actually
the decency the generosity if you visit
the Middle East and don't talk about
politics and you walk in the streets the
people are kind in Egypt the people if
you get lost you find 10 people taking
you're supposed to go so the decency and
the generosity of the Muslim people are
are something at well-known the problem
is that in America when you're a devout
Muslim you you are in yet you're torn
you're torn between your loyalty to
America and defending the indefensible
because some of them are too scared to
speak against that jihad because they're
gonna be called apostates so many many
of them choose to be silent just be
silent about I'll tell you the militant
ones are the ones who the Phantom ass
has bailed out the Muslim Brotherhood
who the ones who say Sharia law is all
good there is nothing wrong with Sharia
law even the resin condemned women to
story they defend that frankly I I can
defend it
the good hearted many many many Muslims
also the problem is we don't know what's
in the box
so they defend it without without
knowledge there's so many many even
defend Sharia without knowing Sharia
because if they say it's almost no I
want to live on it you know these
Muslims you know it I would just live
under illness they don't know there are
good people they just don't know what's
inside the box so it's very difficult I
think the majority of Muslims really a
good good and honest people
the ideology has allows a lot of
inhumanity and barbarism the gorge of
Sharia but they don't know
but they don't know they just pray and
they think they are many of them don't
know I would I would I would rather
frankly live be born I would rather see
as much as I am NOT a Muslim anymore I
would rather be born to a Muslim family
and they brought up in the ethics of
bringing up the children learn an ultra
liberal family in my husband was born in
an ultra liberal family I'm talking
about the ones that really really hurt a
chance I was an experiment I rather be
brought up by a nice fan Muslim family
who who just praising music then than
the experimental psychological love
I have friends oh and brought up and
they had to go under a lot of point that
you've made is that Sharia oppresses
both Muslims and non-muslims so my
question is how do we get from this
situation right now which is depressing
and frightening to a solution it seems
everything you've said leads against
them change the system they get 75% of
wants Sharia laws so how do we how do we
fix this problem is a problem it has to
come out decide from inside the money
but how the problem is when they turn on
CNN when they talk they find they find
people who are covering up to the
Islamic course why aren't we showing the
Sharia impact on human beings in our
media because they let me tell you some
Muslim world has a lot of respect for
Western media they turn it on and they
watch it do they approve of us today we
always are scared to show why don't we
show the women who are being stoned or
said of them on our news it's not end up
with an I can use it's not covered by
magazine how many people in the Muslim
world watch time by Time magazine we
want to put it on our regular news so
when they open the TV in the Muslim
world they say this is Sharia law let
you know they need to see themselves in
the mirror they don't we are not just
working when when when why don't we show
the family that were Jewish family that
was killed just recently the dead bodies
the Palestinians are very good at
showing their victims and the wailing
and crying why don't we show the images
of the victims of the jihad we're now
not we're not going a good job it's a
big freaking you have to know what's the
solution
I'm incapable of finding solution the
only solution that I can say is speak
about it
it's stand against it brain like a man
all right so um I guess my question
stems from me being you know a Jewish
queer identified woman and knowing a lot
of Muslims and knowing a lot of
Americans and you know personally in my
relationships and me knowing people and
being surrounded by other people
I feel significantly more threatened by
American paranoid nationalists us than I
do by Sharia law or you know any
shut up all I've ever seen from Muslims
is you know I've lived next to mosques
and you know people have been wonderful
and kind to me and so I just think that
this paranoia and this you know rage
directed religion is just absurd and
become a majority then we demand it and
by the way but you ask the question now
can you please like the answer you have
to like the answer
you have to let me answer her question
she doesn't feel the impact of Sharia
justice and frankly you're right some of
my best nicest friends are Muslims it's
not the people and I said this I don't
know how many times you want me to say
it's not the people that I am afraid of
I'm afraid of surely Allah which is the
law today in Egypt and in all Muslim
countries the other side the Cairo
declaration making Sharia law of the
land and ever all the items I just told
you about are in China do you want to
live in a country where a father must
name his son Mohammed or at much and
never name him that's in Egypt I'm not
saying this is the law in America today
but I want to tell you something just
listen just listen to me I'm not
disagreeing with what you say I won't
feel sorry has impact in America I don't
care about Satya speaking about Sharia
now because I don't want America to have
a Chechnya in the middle in 15 years
what does that mean what does search
near in the midst in 40 years when
Muslims migrated to the Soviet Union
they formed an area called Chechnya and
it was predominantly Muslims and what
happened after they became strong in a
certain area they demanded Sharia law we
are the majority here we want Sharia law
and we want to separate the school we
want a separatist movement today no you
won't get a separate smooth with your
part of the country okay
schools are being blown up tears are
being blown up
every every now and then we hear about
in a dress right Indian let's give you
an example of India India when Islam
went in it lived in harmony with the
Hindu people for a while then when they
became powerful we want our own Islamic
state you want Australia no you can't
have it very India your minority you
want a separatist movement words murder
killing terrorism in India millions of
Indians were Hindus were killed
finally in 1947 and 1947 okay have a
piece of the country here living it
under an Islamic scene Pakistan was
created like that enough no they're
still blowing up India and they still
won Kashmir next they will want more
land we want more of Islamic state look
at the difference between India and
Pakistan they're both the same country
originally like look at the pathetic
state of Pakistan and enormous democracy
you having in in India that's what's
going to happen in America in 50 years
and that's why I'm speaking now because
I will not be here you might be still
here you stay young but you will hear me
we are going to leave to our country to
our children a war a civil war a civil
war to fight an Islamic Civil War to
fight our separatist movement inside the
United States by people who want a
separatist movement because they want to
live under Sharia and that's why I'm
speaking you might not feel it now
because you have nice Muslim friends and
I have my guys Muslim friends young lady
you have to have a little bit vision
just a political question about what's
going on in Egypt to your point about
the fact that I think the Western media
wants to focus on the demonstrators in
the square and to me it feels like they
want us to believe that that that that
is the main demographic of Egypt but
like you said the reality is that you
know it's a very rural country that that
that's really the demographic of the
country and that when you have elections
it's you know you don't just give the
boat to the people that we're in the
square so my question that is is it in
the end though what I what again what
I've been reading is that there that
there's it's really it could possibly
set up to be a big fight between the
Muslim Brotherhood and the military
complex that is probably still intact
that still has the respect to the people
do you think that that could just end up
being the outcome that you're going to
end up with a country ruled by the
Muslim Brotherhood or it becomes a
military dictatorship again we're an
accommodation
military meet they are from the people
most probably 75% of the military in
Egypt are have members family members
and Muslim Brotherhood they sympathize
with them you know a lot of people don't
understand what's the Muslim Brotherhood
in Egypt it's not like the KKK in
America where you can't even find them
the Muslim Brotherhood is so entrenched
in Muslim society not not one family
doesn't have members of it in the Muslim
Brotherhood there's other sympathizers
of a Muslim is part of personal Egyptian
culture so it's part of portion of the
military as well I think there's going
to be an alliance between the military
and the Muslim Brotherhood and we're
going to have the same cycle lot of
people don't understand the cycle of
dictatorships and revolutions in enemies
if this is a way of life in 1952 when I
was just born a little girl there was a
revolution Egypt against the king of
Egypt King Solomon and that revolution
promised freedom democracy freedom and
democracy and actually Tahrir Square at
that time was not called Perry Square
that resolution came to that's a huge
question we're gonna call this the
Hadean square Perry square means freedom
square and they promised them promise -
promise
what did the we Egypt get from 1952
until today we only had three presidents
from 550 and each one of them until he
was dead until Mubarak is the only one
who was ousted alive so the cycle of
revolutions and uprisings and
dictatorships is the stethoscope this is
how it is because Muslim countries they
try to revolt against the oppression but
they don't know that the oppression is
dictated by the Sharia they don't link
it that the actual Sharia is dictated
friendly it is the reason we have
dictatorships in the Middle East is
because
and also it allows revolutions it allows
to the time you can come to power to the
seizure of power under Sharia law so you
can wake up to powers rescission of
power make a revolution if you promise
freedom you promise democracy we try to
give make it more free then the Muslim
Brotherhood tries to assassinate you
so when the Muslim brothers tried tried
to assassinate you because you're
deviating a little bit from Sharia seem
to do it democracy you have to deviate a
little bit function and the minute or a
month another state this relates a
little bit from Sonia Hinda years of
being at a birthday so he goes back to
the Sharia and he goes back to the
Sharia to the oppression so it is like a
schizophrenic personality in one society
part of the society once freedom and
democracy and part of it once general
law and God knows who wins and that's
why they are in constant turmoil between
between the theater ships uprising
dictatorships uprisings because you and
you will never be free of this cycle
vicious cycle until you admit yourself I
have to have separation of mosque and
state if you have separation of mosque
you change without separation of mosque
and state have at your secular
government in Egypt Egypt will never
have peace and democracy yes
which everybody in this room and they
vote for the person who they want and by
the way that person could be like let's
say let's say that they couldn't vote
leader for it our environment inside ice
who's running he is more about an
international person he is very educated
I believe the mechanism Astana when he
uttered the world when he added the
world
let's remove Sharia as the basis for
outcomes he was he was rocks which were
thrown at him right on the street so
what is the message for the person who
wants to bring democracy the message is
you have to polish it so he saw that
Shenyang he thought was check it out
and the vicious jump it goes back
so that's what they want now the problem
is not also than a pedestal not all
systems related by voting are our
threesome okay so hey let's not put them
in the discussion I'd never change
another story please I especially so
let's talk about the problem is yes they
are going to vote their meeting and they
are gonna wait for over 35 years and
we're gonna see another revolt in that
year square and the same thing you're
making every 34 years what your tears
you're going to have a revolution
because because surely Allah is not a
natural way of living is oppressive
people actually live undulate they
revolt but again they don't know the
multi stage system and they have
underneath thinking
until they discovered after another 50
years we discovered it's a vicious cycle
Sharia laws can only produce tyranny and
Germany will produce with oppressed
people and the natural result is that
eventually they'll evolve into a cycle
of tyranny okay we're gonna have a few
more questions but some of the people
some of the people who haven't gone you
see in Egypt to separation of mosque and
state budget and it's gonna be a bloody
bloody fire because it's anybody
removing that number to article two in
our Constitution this is going to be bug
blood in the streets it's gonna be
bloody back it's never not in my life I
had a question and I think that this is
something that I think a lot of people
really want to think about and I noticed
that you said it once I think it's very
much more important to look at you said
that there was a 45 percent illiteracy
rate in Egypt which if you look at that
if that would be if that's statistically
- I've never researched it so they've
never they don't even know Arabic so
what are they teaching in the schools
it's clearly not literacy and they're
they're not teaching probably math or
anything like that so or if they are I
don't know 100% where their test scores
are but there's there's got to be
someone is there a lot are you saying
that well what I'm saying is it's good
education
be the biggest thing here
and she says that she thought the people
and what you're saying is exaggerated or
is is okay let her a juice let her ask
you a question crypt there are
Christians thousands of people have come
together for a revolution for changing
the nation's Muslims and Christians yes
and it's it's not the same way that
you're presenting something an Egyptian
state that is free my family don't we
all okay I hope and succeed here did you
raise your okay here's what I want her
to do where is it two more questions no
I want to show her the article about the
girls whose virginity tests here yeah
Ellucian even in the Middle East today
we succeed because these are my brothers
and sisters in my channel I wish I'm
wrong then I will be the first one to be
happy that that they will achieve a kind
of democracy at least that that's a
little better than before and I I think
they are under way but when or there's
going to be more bloodshed I have no
idea I just where I hope you guys can
check out how incompatible it is with
Sharia